bonjour à vous gérard filoche merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors qu étale ses 70 profession
soit 1,25 million à deux personnes pas
seulement les soignants pour qui la
vaccination sera donc rendue obligatoire
sans attendre que pensez vous de cette
mesure mais priorité à l'information à
l'éducation à la pédagogie priorité aux
institutions représentatives du
personnel à la médecine du travail au
comité de sécurité et conditions de
travail qui concerne directement les
salariés et non pas priorité à la
répression à la menace de licenciement
ou à la suspension du salaire
je veux dire la méthode personnelle
autoritaire fait de zig zag et de
menaces des manuels macron la joue un
rôle de négatif elle oppose des salariés
entre elles posent des français la
boutique à ce qu'il y ait des réticences
à la vaccination où il ya de lever les
réticences
il faut que le le vaccin et aux gens et
non pas imposer les clés gens aillent au
vaccin
moi j'aurais j'observe que dans la
région parisienne l'ouest de paris et
l'ile-de-france est vacciné que le lève
tout le nord et la seine saint denis le
sont à 10 % seulement
donc il ya des problèmes sociaux
inégalitaire il ya des problèmes de
réaction d'information d'éducation qui
ne sont pas traités qui le seront prêtés
par la répression d'un les coûts de flag
les examens et salades sumac rond est
incroyable il est il était en retard sur
tout depuis bientôt deux ans sont des
arbitrages budgétaires ont été complets
santé contre le gel les masques les lits
les soignants les hôpitaux et même là
rjc ce que vas tu sais ce que ce que tu
as et ce maquereau a mal fait et qui
aujourd'hui débouche sur des
contradictions face à la quatrième vague
et pour aborder la quatrième vague faut
surtout pas matraque et il faut associer
les gens justement les employeurs a en
charge de contrôler de la vaccination
des salariés par rapport à cela
qu'attendez-vous des défunts des cas
justement qu'ils montent au créneau pour
préserver le secret médical
quand je dis que les institutions
représentatives du personnel doivent
être développées renforcée à cette
occasion se dit une chose essentielle
c'est qu'il faut qu'une consultation des
salariés c'est pas un choix individuel
les salariés ont sont une collectivité
avec leurs syndicats
avec leur comité entreprise avec leur
comité hygiène sécurité sentait et
conditions de travail
il faut que faire marcher sa macro et a
essayé de tuer ça mais il faut au
contraire qu' il y à des discussions
dans les entreprises ces pâles patron
qui décide de la santé c'est pas la
police qui décide de la santé ce sont
les salariés qui créent les richesses
qui travaillent qui produisent tout dans
ce pays
ces eaux qui doit avoir leur mot à dire
qu'ils doivent échanger entre eux sur
les conditions de la vaccination de son
succès d'atteindre des chiffres qui
permettent de lutter efficacement contre
la pandémie au monde entier des gens
réclament des baisses mais aussi en
france et donc les retards pris à
comment récupérer rattraper corrie sinon
par la démocratie si l'on part l'avis
des syndicats
si l'on part le respect de leurs droits
s'ils n'ont pas consultation ainsi que
les sentiments aller jusqu'au
licenciement pour motif que ce soit
si les salaires des professions visé par
la vaccination obligatoire refusent le
vaccin là encore quel recours possibles
pour les salariés selon vous et c'est
scandaleux
de menacer licenciements on est déjà 7
millions de chômeurs ce qu'il faudrait
c'est contrôlé licenciement il y en a
beaucoup qui sont abusifs qui sont faits
pour des raisons de profit
on va pas en plus rajouté une menace au
nom de la santé et il faut contrôler et
limiter et encadrer les licenciements et
je mourrai avec force
il faut que les institutions du
personnel les comités des salariés
fonctionne et c'est à eux trouver les
solutions entre eux font pas que ça leur
arrive d'en haut de l'elysée dans chaque
petite entreprise
on a un million deux cent mille
entreprises depuis quand on a un
dictateur qui nous lie faut faire s'il
faut faire ça pour faire fonctionner les
institutions représentatives du
personnel pour faire fonctionner le
droit des syndicats pour faire
fonctionner la médecine du travail pour
faire fonctionner tous les moyens qui
permettent au collectif des travailleurs
d'agir ensemble pour se protéger et il
faut que la sécurité sociale collective
c'est à dire l santé publique
les hôpitaux publics aides et contribue
à ça on n'a pas besoin de ça on n'a pas
besoin de cheval
on a besoin de démocratie pour les
salariés pas de sanction pas de licence
une dernière question gérard filoche ça
concerne le projet de loi d'extension du
patin et arqués actuellement aux mains
des députés
cet après midi avant de passer au sénat
ya des manifestations devant l'assemblée
nationale donc on voit que là aussi
c'est une mesure qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité votre avis là-dessus
c'est le résultat de ce que je viens de
dire de la politique de maquereaux il
suscite l'inquiétude il suscite des
oppositions au lieu de rassurer de faire
progresser la conscience de tout le
monde de mettre ce qu'il faut coûte que
coûte tous les moyens pour que ça
fonctionne ce sont ces zigzags ces
retards cetc ses coups de gueule
personnels qui font que ben voilà il ya
des réticences il ya des gens qui ne
voient pas bien l'objectif est qu'ils
ressentent pourtant les menaces de
licenciement ou qu'on les ménages dans
leur travail et pour que ça répond
vraiment il faut changer tout faudrait
changer maintenant
mais faudra changer toute la méthode qui
a été mise en oeuvre
et je répète pédagogie et d'explication
incitation au vaccin
et pour arriver à des objectifs
suffisant pour convaincre ce bacille ce
souk au vide et c'est de ce virus et
qu'on ne réussisse à libérer les gens
aient leur faire retrouver le goût de
vivre mais dans une démocratie pas dans
un pouvoir à la schlague dans des
entreprises d'ici c'est le patron qui
décide où met dehors si vous faites pas
une piqûre il faut expliquer pourquoi
fois une piqûre aux coiffures bates
feraient les gens il faut qu'en
puissance la nécessité de nous faire
jamais je n'insisterai assez sur la
question de la démocratie contre toutes
les méthodes de maquereaux merci à vous
un g1 finage porte-parole de la gauche
démocratique et sociale